the first thing you can see I've drawn
is my rectangle this is my Universal set
which in this case is our school the
teachers in our school anyway now I'm
going to draw some circles on here first
question is should the circles for
teaching maths and teaching other
subjects should they be separate or
should they overlap okay I'm thinking
suddenly realize opere pressure okay the
circles should overlap now there's two
ways to know why that is the case reason
number one have a look at the question
itself like they read this thing that I
wrote in red for you right the question
itself tells you how many teachers can
teach maths and another subject which
somewhat implies doesn't guarantee like
the answer could be zero but it's
somewhat implies that I think there are
some people who can do both right now
the way you can confirm for yourself
without the question sort of asking it
is when you have a look at the numbers
remember we did this yesterday with I
think it was people who bought milk and
bread do you remember that we looked at
the numbers and when you look at 20 plus
a hundred 21 plus 29 what do you get 170
see you like hold on a second
I've got 170 when I add up but I don't
have 170 bodies to assign to those
things so there must be some over does
that make sense okay so given that I've
got my two circles if you haven't
already please make sure you label what
the circles are because I don't just
want numbers flying around and I don't
know what they indicate so I'm gonna put
here maths and other subjects mats and
other subjects I'm going to try and work
out who teaches what okay so where did I
begin last time I actually started with
this piece of information it it's
written last but you actually it's
easiest to put on first who are these
people by the way people who don't teach
within the school there's lots of it
what ups do they do like okay so I'm
gonna put them outside the circle I will
write them there thank you see any but
can someone tell me what are they who
are these people yeah Jessica
I think mr. Johnson would be upset if we
put him outside the circle because he is
an English teacher but I guess yes
surprise every now and then you'll find
him in a classroom Louise who can you
think of ok people who clean the school
they work either important like school
can't function without them but they
don't teach who else yeah the office
ladies the general assistance the
science lab staff the list goes on right
so we have a lot of people who don't
have any qualification to teach but they
are part of the school nonetheless so
I've got them they're represented ok now
from there I then have a look at some of
the other information ok now you can do
this a couple of different ways but I'm
going to say first how many people have
I got left to put into the diagram I've
counted up 29 saw a hundred and a
hundred and thirty six I believe 136
because this is how many people I'll
have in the end and I subtract 29 and
check my arithmetic I think it is 136
okay so I'm going to put 136 people into
here right but I know that 20 of them
will be in this circle do you agree that
20 will be in that circle okay
so I'm going to take that 136 number and
I'm gonna say don't worry about those 20
now so 136 take away 20 gives you what
116 this is the only place left in the
diagram for those 116 to go let me say
that again okay 136 people are going to
go inside the circles I know 20 will be
in here so this is just the final spot
that's left does that number agree with
you that okay Louise you have thought
let's finish this way and then we'll
come to your way and we'll see if we end
up at the same spot is that okay
all right I've got this in-between bit
right because there's more than 116
people who teach other subjects how many
other
there are look look it's it's in the
question is 121 who should be in that
right-hand circle and so far I've
counted 116 of them how many left over 5
right 160 plus 5 gives me way of 121 now
at this point I've actually answered
this second question though I know now
how many teachers can teach maths and
another subject it's that number okay
I'll come back to that in a second I
just want to finish off the diagram
what's the final number where'd you get
15 from 20 minus 5 we know there should
be 20 people in here we already counted
5 of them
there's the 15 left overs so you've got
these five who are the focus of the
question right
there people like me so I don't just
teach maths I also teach computing
studies people like ms Saxena
she's a math teacher but she's also a
science teacher so there's a few of us
poking around but I just kind of made up
these numbers now the ways you suggested
a different way of going through this
what did you do instead okay okay right
alright so just you did the same thing
yeah so you added up all of these
numbers and you're like I'm 5 over I've
got 5 more than I'm supposed to write so
the extra 5 they must be in here people
we've counted twice is that basically
how you do it so that's why that's 15
and that's why that's how you teach me
yeah sure
so I will point out that fantastic we
works and that logic actually does pan
out there's one little thing that I just
want to caution you for at the moment
the situation's we're looking at have
got two overlapping circle with circles
there is that make sense what if I had
another one
this becomes a bit more complicated
doesn't it what if I contemplated people
who taught maths and other subjects and
then I picked out one particular subject
like computing studies right then it's a
little more tricky you've got more
numbers flying around and this strategy
becomes less useful but in this case for
this simpler one it did work are you
happy with that
that makes sense